um so thanks for the introduction indeed
when i know each other i guess from the
start of jobs yet jets whichever you
would like
i myself am a professor at yachts so
professor at the university of tilburg
in data science i work a lot on bandits
contextual bandits and that's what i
talked about two years ago
and i think also two years ago i very
briefly talked that we were in some ways
entertaining this idea of of starting a
startup
that ended up being called scalable and
and we did basically so two years ago we
started up by now we have some funding
we grew the team to about eight people
right now so we're kind of growing and i
want to share a bit of of what we're
doing why we're doing it and get some
feedback there so that that's mainly the
topic of the talk um
hmm
i was expecting more
of this kind of button thing
let's see
i should point it in that
direction i'm really trying
your way around
this is pretty impressive
um
there's people upstairs that can
probably go to the next slide
i don't know like a bunch of stress
people running around my first slide was
a bit of background about myself by the
way so as i already briefly introduced
myself
i'm just gonna keep trying to actually
get this going um
yeah it's nicer to have some pictures
we'll see what happens
none yet
um
but
let me just dig into the to the topic so
what i wanted to talk about today
is kind of why we we started working on
scalable and what we're trying to do
with scalable is what i would call
applied ai on the edge why we're doing
this and kind of why in some ways we
started building the technology that we
ended up building i'm still trying to do
this button but still not working um and
i want to first share
effectively
kind of a few projects that i've worked
on myself over the last few years
that in in one way or another
um effectively filled so these were
sorry
these were all data science projects
basically that i have worked on
um and that we managed to take like up
to some level but then field and those
failures in some ways are the failures
that we're trying to solve with the
company
still now
so we're just going to talk about this
oh interesting
yeah so here on this plot um no
no no clue
but i'm just going to talk about these
four projects and dig right in and
ignore these slides and once the slides
are up we'll get back to them so kind of
over the last i would say 10 15 years i
did my phd about 15 years ago uh 12 12
years ago i've worked in various
positions kind of in data science both
in academia and in industry
and
all a number of prop
projects i would say that i've worked on
which are in in very diverse fields
which in some ways i think is one of the
awesome things about working in data
science is that you can work in very
diverse fields work for example no
in in e-commerce or work in healthcare
or work in the industry and actually
have kind of an extremely diverse
palette basically of projects that you
can work on um which i have but but i've
worked and i've just picked out four
projects which you know we're supposed
to be on this slide in some way i've
picked up these four projects that we
managed to take very far but in one way
or another field and the first one is
one that i started 10 years ago and and
that started oh well that became kind of
known as this idea of what we started
calling persuasion profiling and it was
basically an idea of how to
build up e-commerce pages
to become more effective so this is also
where a lot of my bandit work and stuff
came from it's like oh you have this
page how do you build it up if you have
loads of variations of this webpage how
do you build it up such
in a sense such that you gain as many
clicks as possible and
there was kind of some of the work that
i've done in my phd it's kind of
considering the different algorithms to
actually build up these pages
and then we spun out started a company
doing this and we were able to show that
based on
effectively randomized data we could do
offline performance evaluations of these
different algorithms and we could show
that we could increase click-through
rates by quite a large margin basically
so there we had this project we'd done a
bunch of data collection a bunch of
modeling and we had models that in
effect on the data that we have we could
show that we were able to in some ways
increase the business goals so this was
this thing i skipped over on my
introduction fine
here are some of the projects so i
haven't gotten very far in the talk yet
first project that somewhat failed was
this kind of recommender system in
e-commerce it worked fairly well on the
offline data we never got to implement
it truly we collaborated with
booking.com at the time
which was still a cool company at the
time i don't know if i could say these
kind of things
but in any case
we collaborated with them and we ended
up not necessarily implementing that
algorithm on their live web page because
we were unable to compute
what the next website base would look
like quickly enough before the next page
will be served so we we ended up
implementing some of this on their email
marketing campaigns which are obviously
slower and we had time to compute but we
didn't actually get to the point of
actually putting it live
and some of these other projects
although they're very very different in
nature
all kind of essentially share the same
structure in a sense that after working
with this e-commerce project i've worked
for quite a long time together with
ikanel canel
maintains the dutch cancer registry so
you have a lot of data of
virtually anyone who's ever had cancer
cells in their body in the netherlands
we worked on prediction models for
ejuvent chemotherapy so whether or not
somebody should get chemotherapy after
being like after getting surgery for
colon cancer
um we created
i would say very appealing models even
kind of understandable ones also
relating to the to the previous topic um
we showed on a bunch of the already
existing data that we were able to make
better kind of individualized choices
and in some ways like at least in
expectation increased life expectancy
that model again i think as with the
first e-commerce one it's a useful model
we managed to validate it
we never managed to take it all the way
to actual production in the hospital why
not well for some of the issues that
were already in the previous talk
because it's just inherently very hard
to be in healthcare um we also suffered
from a lot of issues of data privacy in
the end so we had all of this set up on
servers we wanted to have just people
send over kind of patient data we would
you know compute what the next advice
should be
and it's kind of stalled and we've been
searching for ways of getting these
models into the hospitals as opposed to
actually like sending the data out to us
another project we did some something
together with a large consultancy firm
in the netherlands
monitoring the behavior of animals in
slaughterhouses it's not the nicest
videos really
but there we tried to make models to see
if in the end somewhat the pigs
were mistreated basically um and there
as well we kind of created a bunch of
useful models on a lot of their offline
data created or were able to show that
these worked um never got them into
production why not because actually like
streaming all of this data to the cloud
proved to be quite tricky and
predominantly quite expensive for them
final project more recently that hasn't
filled yet i think we're still still
working on it kind of the upper right um
working on trying to predict how much
food a cow should get and it's kind of
these robots are actually delivering
this food to these cows
here we have pretty good prediction
models as well based on the voice of
offline data but now it's kind of tricky
that most of these robots do not have a
stable internet connection to actually
get any of these predictions from the
cloud and then it's kind of how do we
maintain and make sure that these models
are running in a sense on the robots
themselves so these are just a bunch of
projects that i've worked on myself that
you know in some ways were successful
because we created cool models we were
able to show that they were doing well
but none of them actually made it into
production in the way we would like them
to be in production being used at an
extremely large scale um
and i think a lot of that is kind of due
to kind of
how we ended up maybe even culturally
creating these types of applications and
then how creating them might differ from
actually using them so how creating such
a model differs from actually using such
a model so i think it's useful to kind
of and i know this kind of high level
i'll get into some of the nitty-gritty
at some point but
to kind of look at how all of these
projects despite the fact that they are
in very different fields in some ways
came about and if you look at that
basically what you see and i think this
is kind of by and large true for any
machine learning ai process we go
through these stages of in some ways
first making sure we have data i think
actually a lot of projects actually end
there there's no data the data quality
is not good enough whatever this is
where the problems are basically once
you have those and in all of the four
problems that i was just talking about
we actually had a bunch of access to
high quality data and so we we made it
to this next step
which i would call predominantly data
analytics it's really fitting models but
it's trying to understand what's
happening in this data and to be fair i
think a lot of ai machine learning
projects
rightfully in some ways stop at that
stage and this is even likely to happen
for this econo like colon cancer work
that we did so despite the fact that we
never managed to actually run these
models in the hospital which would have
been in some ways our our dream when we
started this project
by understanding some of the data and
analyzing some of the data we now do
know that for specific types of tumors
there's a lot of uncertainty about the
effectiveness of this kind of ejuvent
chemotherapy and it's fairly likely that
we'll be setting up new kind of
randomized control trials for those
specific groups of patients to learn
more about the effect of the
intervention so now we've analyzed that
data and we took some knowledge from
that data and that that is really kind
of the tangible result of our projects
however
you know you can go one step further in
many many of these projects where you're
actually not just understanding this
data but you're creating models often
kind of prediction models that for
example would predict how to build up
the next page and those you can evaluate
on offline data so you can evaluate your
bandit policy on offline data which we
did in this e-commerce setting um
and then
too many projects and maybe some of you
have been in some of these projects
basically and they're saying like oh we
have this model
and kind of on the historical data that
we have it is pretty cool it works well
it predicts well we can make better
choices basically
regretfully a lot of you know
projects i would say stop there um where
all of the projects that i've just
talked about in some ways field is this
last step of then oh once we have a
model that's not just in some ways data
analysis but really it's it's doing
something autonomously it's predicting
something it's generating its own kind
of advices on what to do to actually
move that to large-scale usage so now
all of these decisions would be
automated that this model is actually in
play there's no more humans looking at
it's actually running to actually get to
that last point that's where all of
these four projects
um and that was kind of the idea that a
lot of these projects failed was kind of
the backdrop for what we try to start
doing with the company
but i think to kind of understand why at
least in my perception and maybe you
don't share it i'm happy to hear any
comments kind of after after this talk
why in my perception a lot of projects
find it very hard to make this step from
kind of the model creation to the actual
model usage is because if you think
about how we actually often intend to
use ai and again i think it's fairly
often it's kind of culturally driven how
we try to use these models is that what
we try to do is we
do the first few steps of this little
pipeline
kind of in a cloud environment so we
have our sensors which are kind of in
this e-commerce projects those were just
the web pages so that's the browsers of
people in this kind of uh you know
slaughterhouse big animal monitoring
project with a bunch of cameras in the
uh econo projects is actually the the
electronic patient records that are
running in the hospital so so it's all
of these kind of distributed places
where this data is collected we're
sending all of that data to a central
place
to our cloud and this is where we're
doing all of this data analysis
basically and i think this is what you
know most of you are fairly used to to
have some way of accessing the data in a
central place fitting models to it
understanding what is coming out of
these models to do your data analysis
and maybe even kind of seeing how well
these models perform on this offline
data that you have um but by the time
you then actually want to use a model
like this on a very large scale and
let's let's just zoom in on this kind of
animal behavior project that i was just
talking about so this is data of
pigs being filmed as they're after
walking into a slaughterhouse and
basically what it's trying to do is
whether trying to see whether these pigs
are mistreated and one of the
kind of things that it's trying to
recognize is whether there's enough
space between the big sorry for this
kind of you know maybe two lively
example but that's kind of what's
happening so they have a bunch of data
there that these models were trained on
and initially what we're trying to do
is effectively do this round trip
also
when
basically after fitting the model so
we've done fitted this model we can
predict whether there's too little
distance between these pigs and now
we're gonna have multiple of these live
camera streams that are being streamed
up uh to our in someone's microsoft
cloud in this case where we're running
these models and then the results are
gonna be fed back to this slaughterhouse
to actually kind of maybe intervene if
something is going wrong so that round
trip
proved to be extremely expensive it also
proved to be way too slow in these cases
um
and there i think was in some ways maybe
maybe stupidly but one of my first kind
of
encounters with this idea of why not
after finishing this model training bit
so after you have a model that works
well
why not just move it move it downwards
move it to the location have it run as
close as possible to where that data is
generated and where the results are
actually necessary and this is in some
ways what i try to allude to with my
title of this talk of applied edge ai is
kind of moving some of these models
whether they are ai or machine learning
whatever you want to call them and some
of these models that actually automate
some tasks so i'm not talking
about training models i'm really talking
about once you have a model that for
example recognizes now is there too much
distance between these pigs or that
recognizes how much food should the
skull get or that kind of recognizes
this specific patient should get
chemotherapy as soon as i've trained
this model now i'm thinking about using
it at a large scale why not use it by
pushing it down kind of to where the
data is generated as much as possible
why is that a reasonable thing to do
i think there's many advantages of doing
this so moving these trained models to
what we're calling the edge so closer to
where the data is generated effectively
leads to higher just inference speed
because you don't have any network
latency and these kind of things it
often leads to cost savings you don't
have your cloud cost you can often run
stuff on devices that are already on a
location i also do think actually a lot
of people really overestimate how many
computational resources are necessary to
run for example relatively complex
vision model so even these models that
are trained to see how far these pigs
are apart
we can run them on basically industrial
gateways that have some processing on
them so we don't need large gpus to run
any of these by the time we've actually
trained that model and really tried to
condense it we can run it on you know
fairly
small hardware i would say so you can
push it down reduce the cost you can
make sure that your data doesn't leave
the site so in a sense increase the
privacy especially when this is data of
people and when you're filming people
for example even with kind of gdpr type
rules it is even in many cases
just impossible to send
like live data streams to your cloud so
processing on location is appealing and
you save a bunch of energy by not having
all the data move back and forth
basically so there's
i would say and this is something that i
i kind of didn't know about at all when
i started just doing all this banded
stuff on the cloud but by moving more
and more to these kind of vision
applications on location to these
healthcare applications
kind of became aware of of the i would
say large advantages of moving some of
these models down to kind of closer and
closer to where the data is generated um
and again i'm i'm not trying to say that
this will be suitable for any
ai or machine learning project i'm just
trying to argue that there are such
projects and there's quite a large class
of projects i would say
a lot of vision projects for example
would actually benefit from moving that
processing down after your model has
been trained instead of actually moving
all of your data to the cloud um
now i hope that somewhat somewhat makes
sense but then if it does you can
immediately start to wonder like why
isn't this happening at an extremely
large scale why isn't this like common
to just move all of these models to the
edge
and i would say well there's two
responses to that one is it is getting
more and more common so it is there's a
big stream on kind of tiny ml people
moving machine learning
models to kind of small mcus to moving
them to edge devices this kind of edge
ai idea i think is really kind of
growing and there's more and more
companies in that space
so we hope we'll survive basically we
moved into the space and we now see it
kind of exploding um but the other end
of things is
that it is fairly challenging to
actually move these models to these edge
devices and why is it challenging i
think that the easiest kind of way of
thinking about why it's challenging is
because the edge
is much more diverse than your cloud is
like the edge is a whole collection of
all kinds of different devices
that are there predominantly because
they are often already doing something
else so these gateways might already be
you know doing their gateway stuff um
they might have very different
processors you so you might have been
training
you know on your intel stack and now you
want to move this model to like an armed
32-bit device basically or even to a
smaller mcu so so you have to think
about how do i cross-compile these
models um
maybe just using your kind of
containerized setup that we're very used
to in the cloud will not actually work
on these devices because even kind of
your standard docker container would
give you like one gigabyte of overhead i
would say just memory wise it's very
hard to actually push to to some of
these smaller devices so you get into a
lot of i would say in the end kind of
engineering challenges but you also have
to understand very well kind of the
models that you're fitting if you want
to overcome these engineering challenges
because obviously the more kind of
compressed or the more concise you can
specify your model the easier it might
be to actually move it to these devices
so so i think really oh there's this
kind of idea of moving these trained
models to these edge devices that idea
is reasonable for various reasons but
now it becomes a technical challenge of
actually doing that well um and that's
that's some of the stuff that we've
tried to work on basically
and i'm just gonna spell out some of the
some of the things we do to actually
make some of these projects work and
make some of these projects move to the
edge um it is definitely not the only
way you can go about there's more kind
of unfolding this is really a moving
kind of field i would say so there's
more and more players in that field that
are exploring different solutions i'm
just going to say what we do because i
know what we do but again if you're
interested in this hai field make sure
to kind of explore that whole space i
would say um but effectively what we do
is kind of on on this image
what we do is we take
effectively models so often we're kind
of interacting with people that are on
the left side of this plot it would be
kind of a data science team people
creating these models whereas on the
right side
it'd be often kind of this embedded
systems team or people that are
maintaining the actual hardware that i'm
maintaining kind of the the
infrastructure that's there on location
so we're moving between these two kind
of teams or or different roles in a
sense and what we do is we heavily rely
on what's called o nx onyx i don't know
how people pronounce it
who knows like who knows of o and x
let's use it at all
i'll have a few slides on it's basically
a way of storing
a model it's slightly more broad
actually storing a whole kind of data
processing pipeline in a standardized
way the nice thing about this is that
it's not an implementation of that
pipeline it's just description of that
pipeline which then you can still kind
of operationalize in pretty much any
platform that you want so now you have a
platform independent way of storing all
of the operations that need to be done
to come from the desired input to the
desired output and if you just think
about what is actually happening for
example in that kind of animal welfare
project it's just images of big so
that's your input and the output is are
they too close together yes or no
basically the logic in between is
something you could specify in one index
you can describe how to convert this
input to this output without actually
having an implementation of it so it's
not kind of it's not an executable it's
a description of how you would build
something that can be executed to turn
the desired input into the output i hope
that was not too abstract but kind of
what it's trying to do what we then do
is we take that and we convert it to web
assembly
web assembly is kind of this
one way of thinking about it it's kind
of it's intermediate representation that
normally you would go through if you're
trying to compile this thing like if
you're if you're compiling an
application
but that's optimized for portability
what does that mean basically it means
that we can run
on the device
a very small what we call runtime it's a
very small bit of software that is
compiled for that specific device so
whether it's an mcu or an arm chip or an
intel chip it's a very small bit of
software smear very small it has 65 kb
of memory footprint in kind of a small
so it's it's really a very different
beast kind of compared to any kind of
containerized solution and i can run
this web assembly binary basically so
now i have this portable thing that is
just describing my pipeline nothing else
that i can move to this device
and run it now obviously on a device
you'll need to code around to actually
make sure that the input and output are
correct and whatever that you you know
that the data has been passed to
wherever you want to pass it but this is
kind of the basic of what we do we we
take kind of stored model pipelines
convert to web assembly and push them to
these devices and make it possible to
kind of push them basically to
coordinate which device runs which model
and kind of try to solve all of those
hurdles in between
um i think generally if if this is not
of interest to you at all um great or
not great it's only five more minutes so
you'll survive let's just put it that
way but i do think you want to look a
bit at what this onan x is it started i
think two three years ago people start
developing it uh predominantly driven by
people from microsoft but it's now kind
of it is now really rapidly growing i
would say that ecosystem um and in the
end
onyx just specifies kind of the
computation so the the operations that
you want to do on some input
to produce some desired output as this
kind of directed acyclic graph with
operators so operators might just be
like add two sensors that are coming in
um and kind of the the edges in this
graph being the densers so the kind of
generalizations of vectors matrix
tensors fine the data that's being
flowing that's kind of moving from one
operator to the other yeah so onyx is
just a description of this it's a
description in in protobuf it doesn't
really matter in this case but it's just
a description of given my input what
operations do i do to create the desired
output and this might look very simple
but you can have actually like very
complex like deep neural networks you
can specify this way
and there's this set of operators that's
available you can even create your own
but i think the the kind of the selected
set is very broad and very expressive so
you can create these graphs and
effectively store fitted models also
store
full data processing pipelines so a
bunch of pre and post processing you can
just add to this onyx graph
and now you have a representation and
what i really think is important about
this now you have a representation of
your learned model full pipeline that is
not tied to your infrastructure at all
basically so now you have a way of even
like storing and versioning fitted
models and fitted pipelines then if you
move from your python stack to whatever
else you want to move to that at least
you have kind of this single source of
truth of what your model should do so i
think onyx as a tool for just more
generally data scientists is extremely
awesome
we're happy we're looking at it it's a
bit challenging to work with although
things like pytorch
tensorflow will just readily export to
all linux basically so you can just save
things in onyx format but if you want to
kind of
edit some of these graphs and edit
you know some of the pre and post
processing it's possible it takes a bit
of getting used to um but we ended up
generating i'm just going to skip
through a bunch of these slides but we
ended up generating a bunch of python
tools to actually do this so if you ever
want to work with onyx we've open
sourced a bunch of our tooling
and effectively if you want to
manipulate these graphs to add like you
know pre and post processing uh play
around
admittedly here as well this is an open
ecosystem it's growing there's there's a
few packages out there that are trying
to combine like some of these
functionalities on nx not sure if this
one
will be the one surviving we'll see i
hope somebody at some point just pushes
together all the other tooling that is
there to make it really accessible um
but
we are able which i think is kind of
cool to use on nx
um to really kind of construct just
through very very simple python syntax
constructs our own pipelines from
scratch
and that makes it possible to do things
like this basically which i think is
kind of cool um that right now you can
just say look i wanna like identify
count recognize know where specific
objects are i just wanna count the
number of cars
fine if somebody does a query like this
we can spit out in our next model that
given that it's fed an image will give
you the count of the number of cars
that's there basically and that model we
can kind of compile to webassembly and
just send to whatever kind of edge
device that we want so we're really
reaping kind of these benefits of this
flexibility of onan x to kind of
construct not just the model because
like one of the things we would be using
here is just like a yolo of a5 model or
something as kind of the base model
we're just adding some you know pre and
post processing to it to make it
functioning for something that somebody
actually wants and then move that to
this edge device um
i am almost running out of time so i'm
going to skip through a few things here
we
we try to patent this we'll see how that
goes um but effectively what we ended up
doing is implementing all of this on a
bunch of edge devices we are heavily
collaborating at this moment with
advantage do people know advantage
kind of interesting they're like the
largest manufacturer of industrial
routers and gateways in the world um so
they're actually a fairly big taiwanese
company and they build like they ship
these kind of blue boxes but they ship
all kinds of things they make industrial
pcs and these kind of things they're
really big in that market
and they are right now
shipping well these these small blue
boxes here that are on the lower right
with our runtime pre installed so
effectively the software that can
basically eat up this web assembly
packet is already on that router even
more we've kind of made it such that you
can basically just configure the cameras
that you're attaching to it and the rest
endpoint or modbus or kind of whatever
format that you want to send the results
to and then you can just download a
model and run it on that device so
effectively
if i go back here what we really try to
do is together with them
is take away all of the engineering on
that side basically make all of that
just configurable
the only thing people need to do is
create a model and just push it to that
device um
so then we have these kind of kits you
can just configure on the router itself
so this is a router installation menu
you can do this with config as well but
effectively you can just push these
models directly to for example gateway
run up to four cameras and do things
like license plate recognition or count
the number of people or see whether
there's enough distance between people
which you know suddenly becomes topical
again or you know count the number of
bikes or like any kind of vision model i
guess well not any many vision models
that you can envision we can actually
run as routers which with obvious limits
because if some of them are too large
these routers the one i was just showing
that's an arm 32-bit chip it is
reasonably fast we can run like for a
and pr for example we can do about 12
frames a second to recognize license
plates if you want to be much faster
than that or if you have much larger
models
okay at some point you know you're just
you know ex
basically the capacity of the of the
device you run out and this is again
some of the the challenges is in making
sure that you you have a model that once
you push it to a device that you know
how well it's going to work on that
device that you can predict like how
much resources it's going to take how
fast it's going to run whether it's
going to run and that's what we're
really trying to optimize right now um
that's pretty much my talk google and i
think really wants me to stop right now
because i'm at zero i'm gonna go to a
few slides of what people are doing with
some of this technology so people are
doing things like in retail just
counting the number of people seeing how
busy it is in various places
this is a different application because
predominantly it's different models if
you're trying to count like oh is this
like you know hundreds of people versus
just counting the individual people it's
a different model that's underlying it
um we're doing some sensor anomaly
detection it's also running on these
gateways but now the inputs are
vibration sensors that's done together
with soppy a large paper manufacturer
doing blurring on the edge so actually
sending out images but making sure that
on basically the gateway the people are
already cut out for privacy preservation
reasons doing aprs what i was just
saying some surface crack detection on
drones different type of hardware but
the same runtimes being installed um and
we've done but this is really small mcus
recently like recognizing the type of
coffee beans in a coffee machine kind of
using a similar setup we'll see how they
go that one goes but it's kind of
related to some of the people here let's
just put it that way um that's all i
wanted to share for now i hope this was
somewhat entertaining thank you
no you go and troll
i think you've had practice now
you can make it to the back oh there you
go
hey he's working hello
well i can hear you anyway so that's
fine
so um i'm curious
modern programming language are solving
this problem by
compiling to llvm which can compile to
any platform yep so i'm curious why
can't you just use one of those
programming languages
yeah so as i said editor there's loads
of different in some ways ways of kind
of trying to tackle this problem
one of the things that i find appealing
about the way we're trying to do it is
that you you effectively compile your
runtime to the target once but the model
that you're sending kind of the web
assembly model specification is the
exact same all the time so you don't
need to know at the time when you're
creating this model pipeline what device
you're actually going to send it to
basically or have to compile for that
specifically um so i think that's one of
the things that i find appealing in that
sense but you know
okay
but i guess the programming language is
kind of like a like o nx for llvm so
it's also just a specification for the
compiler that you've got yeah yeah okay
but it compiles on the device
the so this is one of the tricky things
is yes there is some kind of so web
assembly in some ways is the the latest
step of the or the final step of the
compilation happens on the device so
it's again it can really be thought of
this kind of intermediate format uh
before then kind of it's finished on the
device so to say which also means by the
way that if you really want to optimize
for speed
uh you would not necessarily just kind
of store the web assembly binary but
store the
you know finally compiled version that
is actually on the device and run it
from there
all right
who else oh yeah no
hi uh thanks for the presentation uh
i was just thinking i mean you would
still need the cloud infrastructure
right to gather all the data see the
data drift and also for the deployment
of the updated models on the chips
is it it's kind of an interesting kind
of aware
like how much new data do you want to
collect to keep training for example uh
and do you need to cloud input so so the
the simplest way with the way kind of we
put this together if you just want to
recognize license plates by the time
you've downloaded that model onto the
device you can unplug it effectively
from the internet and will keep running
but it will obviously keep running only
that specific model and it will not you
know get any better or whatever it will
just be this model um
i do think but maybe there's some
something where you a lot of you would
disagree i would say that there is a lot
of kind of
applications of machine learning and ai
models where you are not all the time
trying to retrain actually the people
generating these models would have to
collect loads of data and you know put
in a lot of processing to create a model
but once that model is there you might
want to use it in a lot of different
situations where you're not necessarily
concerned in getting new data we're
trying to do some of these things now
where like if the predictions are super
uncertain that we're capturing a frame
and then either like storing that
locally or sending that to the cloud so
that we can use it for retraining so
we're we're definitely getting into some
of these more hybrid modes but right now
we're really approaching the training
and something that's totally separate
from the from the using of these models
you